das ist Südeuropas drogenhafen Doris in
Albanien wir sind unterwegs mit dem Zoll
es ist die Ausnahme dass wir hier
drinnen dürfen Europa soll sehen dass
Albanien anders ist denn Albanien will
in die EU
sie zeigen stolz ihre Erfolge im
Lastkahn spürten sie kürzlich knapp 60
Kilo Kokain auf in einer Ladung Bananen
aus Ecuador 50 Kilo doch viel bleibt
unentdeckt meinen Experten die Macht der
Drogenmafia reicht bis in staatliche
Strukturen Albanien gilt manchen deshalb
als nakostart
unübersehbar ist auch das tatsächlich
einiges getan wurde ein moderner Scanner
durchleuchtet nun Verdächtige Container
10% aller LKW das ist mehr als der
europäische Durchschnitt das Terminal
ist abgeschirmt und überwacht aber erst
kürzlich wurden wieder einige
Sicherheitsleute verhaftet Verdacht auf
Korruption
und zwei Innenminister mussten bereits
gehen wegen Amtsmissbrauch oder
Verbindung zur Drogenmafia der jetzige
aber meint
dass wir ein großes Netzwerk von
Angestellten des Hafens Doris
suspendiert haben und strafrechtlich
verfolgen zeigt doch unsere
Entschlossenheit den kompromisslosen
Krieg gegen den Drogenhandel zu führen
mehr trafikimi wir haben in Doris
äußerst lobenswerte Arbeit geleistet wir
haben in den letzten Jahren Tonnen von
Kokain aus Lateinamerika beschlagnahmt
wie bereit ist Albanien für die EU im
Kampf gegen Kriminalität beim Wohlstand
an die kommunistische hota Diktatur
erinnern nur Bunker
der Wohlstand wächst
Tourismus bringt Geld ins Land
und die Jobnomaden in der EU man sieht
es jeden Dorf an wenn Verwandte in der
Ferne arbeiten
[Musik]
drei Söhne von xevahiri Karai sind
abgewandert nach Griechenland und
Deutschland
Hühner züchten selbstversorgung ist für
die zurückgebliebenen alten kein Spaß
sondern Notwendigkeit
200 euro-rente ist normal ohne
Überweisung aus der EU geht es nicht
erzählen Sie mir und auch dass sie auf
einen schnellen Beitritt hoffen die
Kinder im Ausland helfen uns sehr weil
wir mit unserer Rente nicht überleben
können erst recht nicht jetzt da die
Preise so steigen
wenn wir in der EU wären würden viele
Dinge besser werden wir hatten bessere
Standards es gäbe mehr Arbeit und du
Arbeit hast dass du Geld hier gibt es
nichts
das Leben von hochzeitsschals reiste es
auch nicht raus 20 Euro bekommt rakibe
für viel Arbeit aber sie sagt selbst es
macht dir vor allem Spaß und mir auch
wir verlassen das Dorf an der neuen
Autobahn gibt es keine Raststätten aber
melonenstände
[Musik]
zwei Stunden später
Boomtown Tirana der neue Glanz hat oft
dunklen Ursprung
[Musik]
hier wird mit Immobilien auch Geld
gewaschen erzählt Journalist Kevin muka
und auch das Korruption und Vettern
Wirtschaft das größte Problem sei
kritische Fragen dazu mag die Regierung
nicht
Business ich fragte eine Ministerin nach
ihrem Ehemann der ist Geschäftsmann und
macht Investitionen die den Staat
berühren das ist ein Interessenkonflikt
für die Ministerin
Premierminister Rama selbst entschied
mich wegen der Frage auszuschließen von
seinen Pressekonferenzen ohne
gesetzliche Grundlage
es gibt sogar ein Video von dem Vorfall
sie durchlaufen wie eine andere Kollegin
nun drei Monate unerziehung sie sind
drei Monate nicht willkommen auf
Pressekonferenzen
Edi Rama macht so etwas öfters auch hier
verhängt er drei Monate sogenannte
Umerziehung für eine Polizisten drei
Monate keine Pressetermine für Sie und
hier beschimpft der Journalisten als
Unwissende als gerüchtestreuer als
Hexenkessel
pressefreiheit ist ein eu-grundwert ob
der Premierminister da gute Werbung für
den Beitritt seines Landes mache frage
ich den Innenminister
die Frage ist ihm sichtlich unangenehm
okay
das ist doch ein Problem das alle
demokratischen Gesellschaften haben was
da auf der Pressekonferenz des
Premierministers geschah sollte nicht
aus dem Zusammenhang gerissen werden
Kevin muka meint sein Berufsverbot auf
Zeit bedrohe nicht nur seine Existenz
sondern solle Journalisten einschüchtern
der Begriff der unerziehung ist eine
Warnung an alle Journalisten wenn sie
ausgeschlossen sind können sie ihre
Arbeit nicht machen und trotzdem soll
das Unternehmen sie weiter beschäftigen
kompania
[Musik]
als sie in Tirana im Juli den Beginn der
eu-beitrittsgespräche feiern freut sich
clevin wie die meisten hier viele hoffen
aber auch dass die eu-albanien zwingt
seine Hausaufgaben zu machen
niemand liebt dich einfach so wir
brauchen die EU nicht die EU
unsiere wir wollen so sein wie andere
EU-Länder mehr nicht
ich meine die EU muss sich hier stärker
engagieren um angebliche Fortschritte
bei Gerechtigkeit Medienfreiheit und in
anderen Bereichen noch genauer zu
überprüfen
am Abend spielen albanische Popstars
gratis Begeisterung ist vorprogrammiert
doch Premierminister Rama seine
Regierung sein Land haben noch viel zu
tun bis zum Beitritt und die EU muss sie
noch wollen es kann also noch Jahre
dauern
[Musik]